okay so when we look at the last of us I
think a lot of us are hit with how
Marley gray that it is Joel's actions
are questionable aliens up going down a
dark path and people have to do bad
things to get by but we can all
understand why this is no matter how
dark things get with the protagonists
there is at least some debate in it with
even the ending of the first game being
like well I get it at the very least
however in the case of David I don't
think there's any point where you can
actually sympathize with him a devious
and manipulative man he attempts to
groom Ellie into joining him in his cult
in both the show and game we learn minor
things about them and in case you don't
know David's one of the main antagonists
in both I think he's being put in place
to show that man is the worst predator
of them all and amongst this new world
he's managed to abuse people and do what
he wants David is far worse than the
infected and he even sees them as being
something to admire before the world
fell apart he would have had to have
moved silently and likely would have
evaded the law due to his manipulative
abilities though he definitely twists
situation to his benefit post-apocalypse
he has even more power because of the
way the world is he's taken his
followers away from the overlooking
guise of Federer and isolate them far
away from everyone else in a habitat
that not many people would venture to
he's very much built the cult Iran
himself and like most cult leaders he's
abused his power to allow him to carry
out his dog fantasies describing himself
as a man with a dark heart we see how
he's letters flock into a life of
cannibalism and that they've been
shunned into silence even when
witnessing abuse now in the show we
learn a little bit about his past and
discover that he actually used to be a
teacher knowing what we know about him
this has an extra layer to it as he
could have used this role to Prey Upon
people this very much plays into why he
likely became a preacher as well these
positions of power give him access to
young girls and it also means that
people will listen to him and turn a
blind eye to what he's doing when all
the issues happen with the Catholic
church we discover that many people knew
about it but they just covered it up
instead of actually damning the person
committing the indefensible tax
religious figures are often thought to
very much be vessels for God and thus in
this position few people question them I
think this is why David chose to become
a holy figure and you know what he says
I don't get the feeling that he's even
religious and instead he views the
cordyceps as the higher power he's a
charlatan masquerading as the leader of
a cause that he doesn't believe in
because it makes him Untouchable at one
point James questions that it might be
God's will to let Ellie die but we see
his own choices overriding this so that
he can get to her David very much brings
the perfect portrayal of his character
to get what he wants as well I think
that both the show and game do an
excellent job of painting him out is a
very meek and meager character who's
completely unassuming when playing as
aliena fighting alongside him and due to
how valuable he is I think many players
will see him as a great Ally in these
moments hell even fooled me and upon my
first playthrough I was thinking he
seemed like one of the quote unquote
good ones up until this point we'd
fought against Federer Bandits and some
the worst people imaginable that were
happy to kill a kid just to get an extra
bit of food David on the other hand
seemed like he genuinely wanted to Hell
belly though and he even sent off his
right hand man to get medicine for her
as players were very much meant to see
him as the people in his town do and be
on his side however the turn comes early
on when he actually plays his hands
slightly and reveals that his men have
had run-ins with Joel and Ali in the
past had you all been in fighting shape
she wouldn't be out getting medicine for
him unless he wants to offer her
something else away from him in this
world most people are in it for
themselves and in the game we even get
the feeling from geology's ditch those
that have slowed him down we saw this
with Henry and Sam too when the Run
truck was chasing them and on the whole
staying with someone if they're wounded
is the exception and not the rule David
incorrectly assumes that at least like
this too but getting someone away from
their families also a tactic that
abusers use psychologists have outlined
patterns like this before and in toxic
and abusive relationships there tends to
be some key characteristics these
involve getting the victim away from
their friends and family and thus
they're more likely to stay with the
person because they have no one else to
turn to in David's Town Ellie would very
much be viewed as the enemy too the
stories of her and Joel have circulated
at this point and I can't imagine that
the town's folk will take too kindly to
her around these pots thus Ellie will
very much be stuck in a strange place
that she doesn't know with no one else
to turn to David will be the only person
that she has unless you'll be able to
manipulate and abuse her without anyone
stepping in to help out it's a sad and
sadistic plan that puts early in the
most danger that she's ever been in
whereas she found a surrogate father
with Joel David is very much a dark
version of that and I don't think it's a
coincidence that he refers to himself as
that in the entry we see as a girl named
Hannah Montana father who was killed by
Joel and David's done a similar thing to
what he planned to do with Ellie I think
that she's very much used in the episode
to show what could potentially happen
with Ellie and we watch as a
congregation refuses to speak up even
though he's hitting her in front of them
it's likely that they would never to
speak up to him at all and you really
feel for the girl in this moment and I
don't think it's any coincidence that
this interaction comes the night after
he just met Ali this slap is very much
him casting her to the side because he
has a new Target that he wants to
control now at the start of the episode
they say it's too cold to bury her
father but it's possible there might be
another layer to this the ground being
too cold to dig up sounds like a bit of
BS and it's possible I can't bury his
body because they've eaten it this would
also mean that Hannah's ate her own dad
and that David was complicit in doing
this it's just got a creepy subtext to
it the people just eat down on their
meals without speaking up they are just
happy to have something to eat and if
it's a choice between a hot meal and
speaking up and starving then they'd
likely rather go with the former David
has weaponized this and often in Cults
you will find behavior that fits along
with this too one of the first things an
abuser will do is also restrict food as
it will allow someone to control those
below them Nexium did it or Kelly did
and pretty much every figure like this
carries out something similar we do know
food is scarce too so it might not be
intentional but potentially David chose
for them to settle here because of that
reason there's also the fact that it's
out in the snow and thus anyone who
tried to leave would have to deal with
the environment too so your choice is to
stay there and be fed or face the harsh
Frozen landscape that surrounds the town
I think all of these aspects are what
makes David the most evil character in
the game and show because of how devious
he is appearing as a mild-mannered man
he's managed to manipulate people into
thinking that he's not a threat when in
reality he controls every aspect of the
life that people have in his town if you
put yourself in their shoes too you can
easily see why some have just chosen to
stay silent and he's preyed upon this
weakness to mean that he can basically
do what he wants if they speak against
him they could be speaking against God
they stop him it might mean they're
unable to eat and if they try and leave
then they have to contend with what lies
around them they've already lived
through fedra and several writers and
now just want some Safety and Security
in exchange for silence it adds so much
complexity to the show but either way I
think we can agree David's a second evil
man I think most people would rather
face up against the infected than be
stuck in a town with him as the leader
but he's used to be able to control them
masquerading as a religious man he's
tapped into people's fears and has used
them as a way to control how they live
it's a harrowing thing and had Ellie
ended up stuck with him then who knows
what would have happened his death scene
is meant to be brutal for a reason and
seeing her cut away into him is done by
the creative team to show just how evil
he is it's complete Overkill and yet you
can definitely understand why his death
is portrayed like this in the end he's
one of the most evil characters I think
I've seen in video games before and the
worst thing is that most players
wouldn't have suspected a thing on their
first run through I think when making
this video something that stuck with me
is just how much of this actually
translates to real life things like
clickers and blow photos don't exist in
our world but people like David do they
come across as kind and gentle Souls but
lurking beneath them's a dark and evil
side put in a position of power they can
destroy someone's life worse than an
outbreak like this have occurred and in
fact it would make them more powerful
without law enforcement and having
people in vulnerable positions means
that they can Thrive and get what they
want it's terrifying to think about and
I think it's a reason why David sticks
with so many people long after they
finish the game to me he's the most
dangerous character we come across and
he's a chilling and evil villain with or
without the infected as always I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the character
and what you think about David in the
shown game comment below and let me know
and if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our video
on screen right now if you want to
support the channel then please join our
membership program by clicking the link
below it'll give you early access to
some videos and we're also going to
start doing some extra stuff that really
really pays you back for all your
support hopefully see you over there and
without the way thanks for sticking
through this I'll be four I'll see you
next time take care peace